Here is a bad sequence of updates for
this particular example.
So I rewrote the value function for all
the different states, all seven states.
They're all remember dot products of
the weights with the feature vectors.
So V(1) can be written as W0 + 2W1.
V(2) can be written as W0 + 2W2.
And so on.
State seven is the weird one,
right, that has 7W0 + W7 and
we have to change the w values so
that we actually are representing
the value function correctly.
So let's consider the case we start off.
We're going to get this process
going with the weights positive and
the value of state seven
much bigger than the others.
And we're going to update
things round robin.
We're going to say
after a transition from
state one to state seven using
the only action that we've got and
getting no reward,
because there's no reward.
We update when we go from state two to
state seven, state three to state seven,
state four to state seven,
state five state to state seven,
state six to state seven,
and seven back to itself.
So these are all the possible
transitions in this MVP.
So we'll just update all
of them one at a time.
And then do it again, repeat.
And just for concreteness, let's say
that the discount factor's point nine,
and the learning rate is point one.
And let's see what happens.
>> Okay.